i
[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález finalizó el
debate de alto nivel en el marco de la
asamblea general de las naciones unidas
en su edición número 75 una edición que
pasará a la historia por haber sido la
primera edición de esta asamblea virtual
de este evento cada uno de los
mandatarios o de los jefes de estado-
dieron sus discursos ante el pleno de la
asamblea virtual una oportunidad que
tienen los líderes mundiales en donde
hablan de sus logros y también de sus
planes a futuro pero algunos se pasaron
de la raya en sus discursos y al hacer
fax ekin la realidad muestra que algunos
de los mandatarios fueron imprecisos
poco acertados y en algunos casos se
echaron un poco más de flores de lo que
tenían permitido algunos medios
latinoamericanos no dudaron en calificar
estos apartes como imprecisiones como
viles y claras mentiras porque los
mandatarios hablan sobre cosas que no
son ciertas sabiendo que las audiencias
de sus países están atentos a estos
discursos que
en algunos pues aparecen puntos que no
son muy claros además están muy alejados
de la realidad de los países cuáles
deben ser entonces la finalidad de los
discursos de los mandatarios en este
escenario de la asamblea general de las
naciones unidas afecta esto la
credibilidad de la asamblea y afecta
esto la imagen de la organización de las
naciones unidas en esta edición del
debate de france 24 hicimos una
selección de los apartes más
controvertidos de estos discursos de los
mandatarios para hacer un análisis de lo
que dijeron
hemos invitado entonces en esta
oportunidad a karina girls a que ella es
asesora senior del centro para la
cooperación internacional de la
universidad de nueva york además es ex
funcionaria de la organización de
naciones unidas también estará con
nosotros hugo coya él es escritor
periodista y catedrático y está también
con nosotros andrés piazza él es
analista y experto en redes sociales
además es director del internet legal
consulting es especialista en derecho de
internet
en gobernanza de contenidos ustedes
también pueden ser parte de este debate
aquí en france24 deje todos los
comentarios en las redes sociales nos
pueden encontrar como france24 journal
piso o guión bajo ese arroba santi logo
que es mi cuenta y pueden dejar los
comentarios con la etiqueta numeral el
debate
efe 24 pero tomó entonces la conexión
con wachovia él se encuentra en la
ciudad de lima como ya decía él es
escritor y periodista y entonces
comienzo le comienzo preguntándole hugo
sobre qué piensa usted y en cuál debería
ser entonces el enfoque que tienen que
tener estos discursos cuál es la
finalidad de este espacio de los debates
de alto nivel que ofrece la asamblea
general
primero muy buenas noches santiago
un afectuoso saludo para usted y para
todos los televidentes y todas las
personas que nos tienen por las redes
sociales
ranz 24 en español y yo creo que hay
aquí hay un hay un problema de origen no
para qué sirve un discurso en la onu de
un presidente la idea primigenia de amos
o pastel debería ser fijar la posición
de su país frente a los grandes
problemas regionales o universales
social pero lo que hemos visto sobre
todo en este en este periodo y ya y es
algo que ya se viene repitiendo con
recurrentemente es que los dos
presidentes no le hablan a la comunidad
internacional y nos le hablan
público oa sus votantes o utilizan esta
tribuna básicamente como aficionado para
echarse flores para destacar sus logros
para en algunos casos incluso para hacer
proselitismo a favor de sus ideas y no
necesariamente buscar consensos o fijar
posiciones príncipes estás que deberían
ser la base de las acciones unidas no
sea el gran el gran foro que reúne a
todos y que definitivamente busca este
está esta unión y más en una crisis como
ésta como de la pandemia bien ha
señalado que ha habido algunas algunos
presidentes no sólo que han pasado de la
raya cómo ha gestionado sino yo creo que
muchos han mentido muchos han
tergiversado y muchos han exagerado y
eso realmente pues distorsiona el
verdadero objetivo para el cual se hace
esta asamblea
ya retomamos la conexión con nuestra
invitada
karina girl y le estaba preguntando
ocarina antes de dar paso a los
fragmentos que la producción del
programa ha seleccionado para ir
analizando uno a uno qué fue lo que
dijeron algunos de los mandatarios
quería conocer su opinión sobre cómo
debe ser entonces el enfoque que tiene
esta asamblea este debate de alto nivel
entre mandatarios que se convirtió fue
en una vitrina para el comité de
aplausos de los mandatarios y de los
presidentes
bueno buenas noches
[Risas]
de contestar esta pregunta y me río
porque llevo 31 años o más o treinta y
cinco años escuchando la misma cosa en
realidad uno tiene que darse cuenta de
que este es un foro en la semana de alto
nivel es un foro en realidad el público
es el público nacional no es el o sea
los partidarios están hablando a su
gente en sus países en realidad no están
hablando y también así van a analizar la
comunidad internacional pero casi
siempre lo que ellos dicen la comunidad
internacional ya no luego ya lo conoces
es realmente lo que ellos sienten que
sería bueno para ellos esto se ha visto
en el caso de bueno no sé si van a pasar
algunos algunos clips pero pero en el
caso de trump en el caso de bolsonaro
de mucho del mandatario pero esto no es
una cosa diferente que años de otros
años porque normalmente es así
si es una crítica que llega a los
mandatarios constantemente pero este año
por ejemplo llamó mucho la atención las
declaraciones que dio el presidente de
brasil usted ya lo decía karina jair
bolsonaro en torno sobre todo al tema
medioambiental y ha costado muchísimas
críticas no sólo en su país sino también
a nivel internacional lo escuchamos un
fragmento
y la nuestra es una selva tropical y
como tal no permite que el fuego se
propague dentro de ella los brotes de
incendios tienden a ocurrir
prácticamente en los mismos lugares en
los alrededores orientales del bosque
donde los brasileños de ascendencia
indígena queman sus tierras perspectivos
en busca de medios de vida en áreas ya
despejadas y ya adiós matadas andrés
piazza en la ciudad de córdoba en
argentina hasta con nosotros para
ayudarnos a analizar este tipo de
mensajes que quieren lograr los
mandatarios más allá de mostrarse que
están logrando sus planes de gobierno de
mostrar que están funcionando sus
políticas y de mostrarse como líderes
cuando en realidad están siendo pues
criticados por diferentes sectores ya
sabemos la controversia que hay en torno
al presidente jair bolsonaro por el tema
medioambiental
a 3 a 2
anunciación es en la asamblea de antes
sus días cada vez más formamos parte del
debate público interno de países y no
tanto el debate del tráfico pero jefe de
estado y en tanto debate público es
comprensible es esperaban el stand de
acciones que existan depende de estados
que se dirijan a sus pasiones bajos
partidos y que tengan su discurso y su
estrategia los hechos históricamente han
existido estas relaciones con los hechos
y entiendo sobre la capacidad de a
cambiado conformaban striker con
capacidad de tiempo real poder
cuestiones de izquierda veracidad del
discurso público y encanto discurso
público en lo interesante es analizar
cómo se propaga cómo se puede cuestionar
en cuanto a su veracidad y cómo a veces
las redes sociales plataformas como
internacionales empresas privadas
multinacionales incluso tienen un
pequeño rol de regulador en algún punto
privado sobre el curso de jefes de
estado no van a personar había pasado y
visitas veces han puesto en ti que estás
en sus propias declaraciones
por ejemplo contrario en principios de
seguridad o de salud pública y han
incluso bajado algunos tuits en alguna
oportunidad del respecto de enunciación
de la pandemia y entonces se plantea una
discusión internacional respecto de
existir en derecho de plataformas o
citan que cumplen una función pública
por eso es una desinformación
pues vamos a escuchar otro fragmento del
discurso del presidente de brasil
jair bolsonaro quien además arremetió
también contra china por ser el país de
origen de la pandemia y del virus de el
cubil 19 escuchamos whitmarsh
debemos responsabilizar a la nación que
desató esta plaga en el mundo china en
los primeros días del virus china
bloqueó los viajes a nivel nacional
mientras permitía que los vuelos a milán
de china se infectaron al mundo
el gobierno chino y la organización
mundial de la salud está prácticamente
controlada por china declararon
falsamente que no había evidencia de
transmisión de persona a persona en
transmisión con la corrección era el
presidente de eeuu donald trump
refiriéndose a china como país de origen
y de donde se empezó a disipar el
coronavirus a lo largo y ancho de
nuestro planeta y pues que nos ha
llevado a meses de confinamiento por la
expansión que ha tenido el cob y 19
impresiones sobre lo que ha dicho el
presidente trump karina ya se ha vuelto
prácticamente habitual en su discurso
arremeter contra china contra el
gobierno contra las políticas económicas
comerciales de derechos humanos no hay
un área que a china no le caiga una
crítica por parte de washington y el
presidente trump
bueno por el pote está hablando en en
las salas y en los corredores de nuestra
comida se está hablando y bueno en
muchas partes se está hablando de una
nueva guerra fría pero esta vez entre
china y los eeuu y una de las razones
por las cuales no se pudo pasar una
resolución en el consejo de seguridad
por persona en el consejo de seguridad
por mucho tiempo o por muchos meses
después de que saliera el comité era
porque efectivamente el presente trump
éste insistía de que se le llamara el
wuhan flu lo cual sigue haciendo pero en
realidad si uno se pone a ver en las
narrativas son las que ya conocemos o
sea no es es no hay nada nuevo lo que
dijo bolsonaro en realidad es una cosa
que ya ni sorprende porque sabemos cuál
es su narrativa en con respecto al medio
ambiente lo mismo trump lo mismo esté
maduro diciendo que todo el drama de
venezuela es
por las canciones o sea son narrativas
que ya se conocen y que ellos repiten
porque es para el público nacional y
luego ellos agarran los clips y ellos lo
ponen en su propiedad en su propia
maquinaria propagandística pues ese es
el sistema y lo que tienen naciones
unidas es que no hay derecho a réplica
no hay derecho a réplica ellos dice
decidieron cuando un presidente como
trump ins o sea acusa como acusó a china
de tantas cosas porque él es un jefe de
estado la única opción que tiene china
es de mandar una nota o sea de protesta
que se circula pero no hay derecho a
réplica a un jefe de estado jefe de
gobierno sí pero eso viene al al final
de la sesión completa entonces en
realidad no es un no es un diálogo o sea
no no se puede entrar una discusión sino
que es este le digo no sea una una
narrativa que cocinados conocemos y que
tienden a repetir jugó uno puede
entender que el presidente trompa haga
este tipo de acusaciones y señalamientos
porque están campaña en pocas semanas
van a ser las elecciones
el 3 de noviembre pero uno ve al
presidente bolsonaro que tiene problemas
allí para hacer frente a la pandemia de
kobe 19 pero que extrañamente para
muchos el día de hoy dieron indicadores
de su popularidad y se ha incrementado
con respecto a los meses anteriores
cuando estaban en el punto más fuerte de
la pandemia y ahora sale a decir este
tipo de afirmaciones y cuando se está
quemando cerca del 22 23 por ciento de
la región del pantanal y apenas hoy han
enviado a delegados de la guardia de
seguridad nacional desde brasilia para
hacer frente a esta emergencia ambiental
entonces como entiende uno ese actuar
que para muchos puede ser errático tal
vez el presidente o bolsonaro como lo
entiende usted
bueno primero decir claramente que lo
que ha dicho
bolsonaro pues es una verdadera mentira
primero culpar a los indígenas por los
incendios son lastimadas como se le
llama en brasil
es absurdo yo tengo la oportunidad de
trabajar muchos años allá en brasil
acompañar un poco la de los orígenes de
los incendios en la selva amazónica y al
contrario las comunidades indígenas
son las primeras las primeras que
combaten el fuego porque es su sustento
básico y las cifras no dejan margen de
dudas sólo en agosto del 2020 ya o sea
en el mes pasado se ha batido el récord
un mes en 22 años desde la cantidad de
incendios que hay en la ósea según el
instituto de pesquisas espaciales 8.030
pocos incendios fueron detectados sólo
en el mes de agosto y los seis primeros
meses del año en brasil se incrementado
a más de 51 por ciento los incendios con
relación al 2019 o sea que por lo tanto
las cifras que son frías y que además
las da un instituto muy serio que
pertenece además al aparato de de
estatal para pagar papeleras de brasil
como el instituto de pesquisas
espaciales no dejan margen de duda de
qué bolsonaro
no digo la verdad en este caso pero
fuera de todo eso respondiendo a su
pregunta ha cambiado porque bolsonaro va
a un oro como la onu hice una cosa como
esa y a sabiendas de que va a la prensa
internacional y que muchos muchos
detractores organismos que velan por el
medio ambiente van a van a cuestionar
porque no está hablando para ellos está
hablando justamente por lo que éste ha
mencionado ahora para las impuestas y
para su popularidad o sea está hablando
a su público y cree y su y utiliza más
bien el foro de la onu para validar su
mensaje entonces él puede colocar en la
en la en las redes sociales en todas las
redes está en el gobierno su gobierno es
decir yo lo dije ante la comunidad
internacional acá está la prueba de que
este tiempo si entonces
el fútbol a la onu se convierte en la
herramienta para validar una un peine
como éste no o una mentira para este el
caso de bolsonaro está en varios medios
internacionales y por ejemplo de la
organización observatorio del clima en
brasil que trabajó todo el discurso y le
hizo fax a kim a cada uno de los datos
dice que el presidente no presentó ante
la comunidad internacional cómo va y no
presentó cómo va a solucionar los
problemas sino que negó los problemas
que hay en términos ambientales no hay
evidencia de que haya unas ong o
científicos o que haya organizaciones
que estén confabuladas con intereses
comerciales para hacer una mala campaña
a brasil como él dijo que brasil está
haciendo presa de la desinformación y
también criticaron la afirmación que
dijo el presidente en torno a que está
buscando la regularización territorial
la regularización contra los delitos
delitos territoriales y las quemas de
zonas forestales como el amazonas y como
pantanal andrés de piazza en la ciudad
de córdoba en argentina como vemos las
cosas y con lo del repunte de aprobación
de bolsonaro superando el 40 por ciento
el día de hoy entonces lo importante es
hablen bien hablen mal pero que están
hablando del presidente bolsonaro en la
prensa internacional
y posiblemente esa estrategia sea eficaz
también es posible que sea eficaz en el
corto plazo
al mismo tiempo todavía no está conocido
el resultado de los diferentes impactos
a tener la pandemia
eso puede ser un aspecto que le pueda
jugar en contra o en este momento
puntual
la el debate público si no se comprende
exactamente cuáles son o cuáles son las
convicciones de la ciudadanía en cada
país respecto a la pandemia pone en
jaque las las convicciones más profundas
de todos en mi perspectiva de estas
herramientas de fax checking y
circulares pueden contribuir por lo
menos a
y perjudicial para la salud de los
ciudadanos como a que cuestiona las
emociones veamos ahora el caso de otro
presidente latinoamericano el presidente
de colombia iván duque que habló de la
de un dilema que ya no hay dilemas entre
amigos y enemigos de la paz esto
haciendo referencia a ese controvertido
acuerdo de paz que ha polarizado al país
y que avanza en su implementación a paso
de tortuga si lo han llamado organismos
internacionales y varios medios de ese
país veamos
hoy en colombia no hay dilemas entre
amigos y enemigos de la paz hoy somos un
solo país que avanza sin importar si el
viento está a favor o en contra
las herramientas multilaterales han sido
claves para la contribución de la
comunidad internacional a este propósito
en especial en cuanto a la reparación de
las víctimas el fortalecimiento del
desarrollo rural la formalización de la
propiedad en los rincones remotos de
nuestro país
hugo coya en la ciudad de lima en perú
este discurso nada más alejado de la
realidad que tiene colombia que es un
país que está completamente polarizado
un país que ha vivido unas
manifestaciones violentas en las últimas
semanas y que muestran divisiones en
torno a todos los temas a la realidad
económica al manejo de la pandemia a la
apertura económica a la realidad social
el desempleo los colombianos están más
divididos que nunca y el presidente dice
a la comunidad internacional de los
colombianos que el panorama es
completamente distinto
pero antes de la pregunta sólo una
pequeña diligencia y solo para
relacionar discursos de trump con el de
bolsonaro los dos están en un proceso
electoral
es cierto en el caso de tram está
buscando la relación para estados unidos
pero bolsonaro va a elecciones
municipales en su país y evidentemente
tienen sus candidatos y esta apuesta
entonces también hay que ver en los dos
discursos dentro de este contexto
digamos que se presenta en la onu pero
pidiendo al en el caso del presidente
edu que el presidente colombia es
evidente que colombia está polarizada
que hay una división y negarlo es como
negar que está en el cual todos los días
o que existe el sol lo que existe la
luna que la tierra es redonda entonces
simplemente negarlo es una forma de
tratar de afirmar a sus electores a sus
votantes al público que los sigue
esto y es la misma lógica que yo creo
que emplean nosotros o sea yo no estoy
hablando acá para convencer a ningún
presidente de de un país extranjero de
otro país de cómo está mi país porque
ellos tienen puentes tienen diplomáticos
en información de la prensa
internacional conocen hilo y yo estoy
hablando a mis seguidores a mi
partidarios a la gente que me sigue
diciendo su presidente tengo una
posición y la posición es colombia está
unida a colombia no hay no hay debate
colombia busca la paz ese es el tipo de
mensaje que niega un poco la realidad de
lo que vemos en la política colombiana
del día a día no hay enfrentamientos y
protestas y críticas del proceso de paz
lamentablemente la ansia de no avanzado
con la velocidad que debería haberse
dado que no se ha pagado a las víctimas
de la violencia no se ha pagado todo lo
que debería haberse pagado y todo este
tipo de problemas que se han suscitado y
que sus invitan y que están pendientes y
que este gobierno tendría que poner
muchísimo más énfasis porque quiere
realmente tener este paraíso que instase
en su discurso duch que no karina el
presidente de colombia ha sido muy
criticado en su propio país los medios
lo criticaron hoy fuertemente porque de
puertas para adentro el proceso de paz
avanza muy despacio dicen que hay poca
voluntad política por parte del gobierno
para la implementación y se ha
reactivado el paramilitarismo y las
masacres que lo hemos visto en las
últimas semanas pero para la comunidad
internacional para ir a pedir fondos
para pedir ayuda a otros países el
presidente si es un abanderado del
acuerdo de paz en las relaciones
internacionales teniendo este escenario
de la onu este tipo de discursos no trae
repercusiones en el mediano plazo en el
largo aliento de las relaciones entre
los países
yo no sé si yo no sé si un discurso hace
tanta diferencia cuando ya estamos
acostumbrados a que a que este foro
y sobre todo en la semana de alto nivel
se utilice precisamente para este como
han dicho este nosotros nosotros este
exponente es para realmente este a
fincar una narrativa que tiene y sobre
todo cuando él
cuando son países por realizados o sea
lo que vimos al presidente eduque decir
es lo mismo que dice trampa aquí para
una cierta parte de la población y la
otra se retuerce y dice cómo es este
cómo es posible lo mismo en brasil yo
diría este país es todos muy polarizados
este yo creo que en la comunidad
internacional como ustedes bien sabe
tiene muchísimo muchísimo invertido en
el proceso de paz
yo me imagino que muchos de los países
que han sido acompañantes de ese proceso
de paz deben estar sumamente preocupados
y me imagino que a otros niveles están
hablando y están hablando de otra manera
con colombia pero colombia o sea he
trabajado en este tema muchos años y he
visto muchas veces que este ellos o sea
el gobierno el gobierno dice una cosa
que a la clara luz del día es
completamente diferente de lo que está
pasando en el país pero si bien se
quiere o sea es lo mismo que está lo
mismo que es otro anp y lo mismo es que
son bolsonaro entonces explíqueme una
cosa usted que es ex funcionaria de la
onu entonces porque le damos tanta
importancia a esta asamblea anual si lo
que están diciendo los mandatarios
claramente sabemos como ya lo hemos
reiterado acá que es vitrina es pantalla
en algunos casos y que debemos tomar
cada una de las frases con pinzas porque
no todo es es tan claro como usted lo
dice porque le estamos dando tanta
relevancia entonces a este espacio
bueno mira yo creo que yo sigo diciendo
que la asamblea general es el único
lugar donde se encuentran todos todos
los jefes de estado y del gobierno una
vez al año este año tuvo que ser este a
través de videos
y toda la parte que es sumamente
importante que se encuentran y que que
hablan todo lo que es detrás de las
bambalinas o sea todo lo que se hace
detrás de las bambalinas aquí en el mes
de septiembre normalmente todos los años
es muy es muy importante ahora yo creo
que y si voy a ser muy franca
quizás vamos a tratar de decir esto de
una manera más diplomática pero hay
ciertos jefes de estado y de gobierno
que o sea como como usted lo puso era
ticos
no particular o sea que tienden a mentir
en sus propios países entonces no van a
hacer una cosa diferente hay una
cantidad de jefes de estado porque yo
estuve escuchando tanto el lunes en el
75 aniversario como el martes del
miércoles
si presentan cosas muy interesantes y
que si presentan alternativas así que si
lo que pasa es que uno tiende a
enfocarse este
en algunos nada más dos o sea que sí
creo que tiene que m que tiene validez
es un ejercicio que es porque si van a
hablar 293 entonces cuando uno llegue al
cierto novecientos mismo ciento
cincuenta
no hay normalmente ni siquiera en los
años o te es el es presencial si alguien
en la sala y ahí es donde uno se da
cuenta más que nada y esto es un vídeo
para la gente que está en carta me
quedan pocos minutos para cerrar el
programa quiero hacer las conclusiones
comienzo con hugo coya en la ciudad de
lima que nos deja de elecciones entonces
esta edición 75 de la asamblea de
naciones unidas primera versión virtual
muchas lecciones muchos mensajes claros
entre líneas no tan claros como lo
estamos analizando porque también hubo
mensajes bastante ambiguos por parte de
manuel macrón de francia así jinping
vladimir putin de rusia que prometió una
vacuna y distribuirse a todo el planeta
cuando ésta esté lista por parte de sus
científicos que piensa usted
yo la verdad como mencionado eso yo
esperaba que el mundo está viviendo una
una gran una de las mayores crisis del
siglo no en términos sanitarios
económicos y todo yo esperaba un acto de
renuncia digamos a los apetitos
personales e individualistas
de los líderes mundiales y buscar más
bien consensos acercamientos para hacer
una gran alcaldía alianza no y de poner
pues ésta usarla la asamblea general
precisamente para éste también
lamentablemente lo que hemos visto es
discursos aislados muchas inexactitudes
hablando sólo para la tribuna nacional
no viendo más allá de sus fronteras y
eso realmente me deja un gran sabor
digamos porque tenía muchas expectativas
a algo como los demás en un ritmo una
fecha tan especial para la onu como el
75 aniversario
todavía el ser humano nuestros líderes
mundiales no estén a la altura de las
circunstancias de que enfrentamos todos
toda la humanidad más allá de donde como
cómo comenzó la pandemia lo concreto es
que estamos en una situación muy
dramática a todos y todos deberíamos
navegar
con la misma dirección para salir de
esta crisis terrible en que nos
encontramos como seres humanos y como
planeta no era tal vez una coyuntura en
la que podrían mostrar un poco más de
grandeza porque algo nos está afectando
a todos por igual no por continentes o
por países sino a todos por igual era un
momento en el que podrían dar un
discurso diferente y karina para el
cierre su conclusión un minuto
yo diría que hay que ver también que es
la primera vez en 75 años que no hay
liderazgo de los eeuu para bien o para
mal y esto ha causado un vacío donde
todo el mundo está tratando y por eso
también mensajes antiguos de china de
rusia detrás de los otros poderes y yo
creo que como dijo el secretario general
hay un superávit
desafíos multilaterales pero un déficit
de soluciones multilateral y realmente
es una lástima muy grande yo concuerdo
con mi otro panelista o sea que esto no
se haya podido este que la gente no se
había podido unir pero cuando las
grandes potencias es que no se ponen de
acuerdo es muy difícil para los demás y
creo que lo que va a tener que hacerse
es buscar coaliciones de países para
educar como por ejemplo están buscando
un grupo de países a ver qué pueden
hacer con una vacuna para que no sea
nada más que en que los la mayoría del
mundo no esté
y la piedad pues de las grandes
potencias además que nos quedan todavía
escenarios difíciles europa está
comenzando la segunda ola de contagio y
se había en ese proceso de desarrollo y
entrega de la vacuna que vendrá a futuro
esperamos que así sea gracias a mis
invitados por estar con nosotros el día
de hoy haber analizado este tema para
nosotros sigan ustedes dejando los
comentarios en las redes sociales sigan
con nosotros
[Música]